so it's not just you're interested in
the oceans or space you've touched and
been touched by engineering and
technology and there was a lot about the
cameras used for avatar but you go
farther back than that well yeah just I
just love engineering I love I love
solving hard engineering problems and I
love working with really smart engineers
in a room and trying to do something
that hasn't been done before like you
know make a sub and that can go to
extreme depth you know there were
materials problems electronics batteries
all sorts of things that had to be
developed that were actually hard
problems and you know I just I just like
that so Charles II like solving problems
yeah so he would have made a good sign
he would've made a good scientist who
had made a good engineer he would have
been a good just about anything he could
have been somebody but that got me
wondering okay what kind of a
preparation what kind of thinking must
have gone in to motivate him in 2012 to
make the first solo descent to the
deepest place on earth in a submarine
that he piloted and code designed Wow so
you know where he went
what's the deepest place on earth the
Marianas Trench dad I thought you were
gonna say my fears all most seven miles
down seven almost seven miles down off
the coast of the Philippines and so I
asked him about that record-setting dock
let's check it out so what motivated you
to go to the bottom of the ocean the
bottom of the earth you know the funny
thing is that I've been asked that a lot
and it occurs to me that a kid would
never ask that question because a kid
wouldn't know you just gotta go why
wouldn't the a kid so dis me in that
moment right there culture we start to
think like what about kid again I know
exactly so a kid would say why wouldn't
you go yeah it's there and and you
haven't looked yet so why wouldn't you
build a you know a sub and get in it and
go and look
[Music]